would you prefer aliens or Jesus be real
Jesus is real he comes back but he looks
just like the tiny little Mexican aliens
that they found like that's just what he
looks like do you nail him to a normal
Cross or do you get a smaller cross well
doesn't he nail himself or how does that
work he does not nail himself well you
know what I mean but uh why would that
is the most Jewish thing you've ever
said I just would like come up to him
like real chill and be like I totally
you know respect everything you're going
through but like would you mind if I get
a quick selfie and just yeah just get
that do you think you would got a
promotion at the NFL if you took a
selfie with
Jesus I
mean yeah